- [Instructor] Consider
the density curve below.
It's depicted right over here.
It's a little unusual looking.
It's more like a triangle
than our standard density curves,
but it's valid.
Which of the following
statements are true?
Choose all answers that apply.
The mean of the density curve
is less than the median.
Pause this video
and see if you can figure out
whether that's true.
Well, we don't know exactly
where the mean and median are
just by looking at this.
But remember,
the median is going to be
the value for which the area
to the right and the left
are going to be equal.
So, I would guess
the median is going to be
someplace like that.
So that's my guess.
My approximation.
That is the median.
And because our distribution
goes off further to the left
than it does to the right,
you can view this
as something of a tail.
It's reasonable to say
that this is left skewed.
Left skewed.
And generally speaking,
if a distribution is left skewed
the mean is to the left
of the median.
So, because it is left skewed
the mean might be someplace
like right over there.
Another way,
to even think about the mean
is that the mean would be
the balance point,
where you'd place a fulcrum
if this were a mass
and you might say,
why doesn't that happen at the median?
Well remember,
even when you're balancing something
a smaller weight
that is far away from the fulcrum
can balance out a heavier weight
that is closer in to the fulcrum.
So, in terms of this first one
the mean of the density curve
is less than the median.
In this case,
or you could say,
to the left of the median.
We can consider this to be true.
Now what about,
the median of the density curve is three?
Well, I already approximated
where the median might be,
saying hey
this area looks roughly comparable
to this area.
The median definitely,
I might not be right there,
but the median is definitely
not going to be three.
This area right over here
is for sure
smaller than this area
right over here.
So we can rule that out.
The area underneath the
density curve is one.
Pause this video.
Is that true?
Yes.
This is true.
The area underneath any density curve
is going to be one.
If we look at the total area
under the curve,
it's always going to be one.
So we answered this question.
I'll leave you with one extra question
that we can actually figure out
from the information they've given us.
What is the height
of this point?
Of this density curve right over here?
What is this value?
What is this height going to be?
See if you can pause this video
and figure it out
and I'll give you a hint.
The hint is
this third statement.
The area under the density curve is one.
Alright,
now let's try to work through it together.
If we call this height h,
we know how to find
the area of a triangle.
It's 1/2 base times height.
Area is equal to 1/2 base times height.
We know that the area is one.
This is a density curve
so one is going to be equal
to what's the length of the base?
We go from one to six.
So from one to six
this base,
the length of this base
is five.
1/2 times five times height.
Or we could say one is equal to 5/2
times height
or multiply both sides by 2/5
to solve for the height
and what are gonna get?
We're gonna get the height
is equal to 2/5.
So if you have
a very clean triangular
density curve like this
you can actually figure out the height
with even if it was
not directly specified.